all right guys bang bang I've got Darius
here Darius I figured a perfect place to
start will be with the Federal Reserve
Mr Jerome Powell came out his famous
eight-minute speech that shook the world
what was your take on the on his latest
comments
his latest comments very hawkish I mean
you don't need me to tell you that um I
think uh this is something we've been
talking about in our research at 42
macro which is we are entering the third
phase of the U.S monetary policy regime
the first phase was characterized by a
Fed that had to catch up to Market
expectations of typing and ultimately
sort of um you know accelerate that
process to kind of get in line with
market pricing Market expectations Etc
the second phase of monetary policy was
the market moving ahead of the FED again
to say hey look all this tightening that
you're doing is going to cause a
significant downturn in the economy and
eventually you're going to have to Pivot
initially the pricing was sometime in
the early part of next year to rate cuts
and probably quantitative easing now
we're I believe we're in this third
phase of the monetary policy regime
whereby the FED officials are talking
out that speculative Pride Weight Club
pricing from 2023 money markets Etc
because the FED understands that in
order for it to achieve its inflation
objectives they have to remain tighter
here for longer and that's the new
that's the new narrative around markets
it's tighter for longer and what does
that mean so basically the market was
like oh cool you guys said you were
going to tighten you did it you can't
keep tightening too much so like at some
point you're gonna have to Pivot let's
because we're forward looking let's go
ahead and position ourselves for the
pivot and the FED basically came out
like you guys are all nuts let's just
we're going to keep doing what we're
doing uh can they keep doing what
they're doing though like they're saying
it can they keep doing it
this is I think this is the the most
important question of the day the long
most important question of the longer
term uh kind of outlook for asset
markets is whether or not the FED will
actually eventually start to acquiesce
to more inflation pressure in the system
by not sort of constantly fighting it
and and trying to get inflation back to
the two percent Target the most
important question of today kind of the
medium term that's more of a longer term
view the medium term is can the economy
handle it and where is the neutral level
of the policy rate go back to uh to to
uh July the fomc meeting where Jay
Powell said effectively that hey look we
think we're finally towards there right
around neutral from the perspective of
the policy rate which at 2.5 percent is
their estimate of long run neutral which
you know if you ask any Economist would
work their shirt you know obviously
Larry Summers is kind of being the the
uh the guy out front on this two and a
half is not neutral in this new US
economy whereby the well any measure you
look at from a wealth effect perspective
stock market capitalization perspective
income inequality the booming labor
market there's very clearly a lot of
organic nominal growth potential in this
U.S economy and so the key question is
will they break something and at what
level of interest rates will they break
something clearly they have not broken
anything yet as evidenced by this
morning's Schultz data and consumer
confidence reports gangbusters data so
when we look at that whole idea of like
they're going to have to break something
people have been saying this for a while
you and I talked about it a number of
times this year uh a lot of folks
looking at their Investment Portfolio
being like it looks sure looks broke to
me this stuff is down a lot what are you
talking about when you say they have to
break something it's obviously not the
investment asset kind of prices it is
these other data points what do you
expect to break and they'll kind of be
the canary in the coal mine that's like
okay we're getting close to some sort of
pivot yeah well the question is I mean
they've done a decent amount of damage
to investment assets but let's not
forget the starting point was basically
a bubble in the stock Bond a
cryptocurrency market so you know taking
a little bit of air off at that that
taking a little steam off that those
bubble tools doesn't necessarily mean
that we've broken anything I mean
obviously s p right now inclusive of
today's decline is still only down like
15 or 16 from its highs from a very
asymmetric all-time high obviously so
it's not really saying it's broken
anything what I mean by breaking
something specifically in the economy uh
specifically is the labor market this is
a U.S labor market we've talked about
many times on the show that is growing
at rates that are effectively double our
pre-covered Trends if you look at
private payrolls growth
um you know on the three-month
annualized basis double uh average
hourly earnings growth double uh private
not or private aggregate private sector
income more than double the you know
pre-covered Trend when you productize
all those different features and factors
so this is labor market as evidenced by
the jolt stator that we just got today
accelerating another 200 000 to you know
11.3 million or 11.2 million rather you
know this is a labor market that is
growing so robustly that the FED has a
significant amount of work ahead of it
still in order to kind of take pressure
out of the system we've got a couple of
charts here the first being core
inflation materially inflected in July
explain a little bit what's going on
here yeah absolutely so this in my
opinion so let's take a step back and
sort of talk about how we got here how
we got from S P 500 3600 to 30 4 300 and
I guess somewhere around 4 000 now off
the drawdown and then how do we go from
Bitcoin 17.5 to you know Bitcoin 24 000
or some thereabouts at the highs of this
rally you know the rally was first
characterized by short covering and and
sort of all targeting funds you know
kind of reducing their short exposure to
risk asset markets the second part of
the rally in my opinion was perpetuated
by fundamental developments positive
fundamental developments one we got um
you know it's a lot of information that
said U.S economy was not only not going
into an actual recession but it was
actually starting to re-accelerate in
the month of July and in the month of
August um whether it be the job support
the pmis obviously we got the August
consumer conference stated that today
this is Gang investors report and then
we got information out of the fed from
Jay Powell at the July FMC meeting that
said hey look we're getting close to
neutral we might slow down obviously the
market our Market misinterpreted that as
a dovish pivot or something that sounded
like a double pivot but that's either
here or there now what I'm trying to do
is explain why the Market's got to where
they got and the third feature of why
the markets got to they got which in my
opinion was the most important feature
of the rally we've seen off the June
Lowe's across risk assets was this
breakdown in core inflation momentum so
to speak to the Chart uh what I'm
showing in this chart uh the light blue
bars show the month over the the trend
rate of month over month annualized
inflation for for those uh inflation
statistics so we have trim mean CPI on
the left next one is median CPI sticky
CPI followed by trim mean pce inflation
that's what consumers actually spend
money on and then the feds preferred
inflation metric which is core PC
inflation so the light blue bars show
where we Trend it at pre-covered in the
five years pre-covered the gray bar
shows the prior month so the month of
June and the blue bar shows the month
over month annualized inflation rate for
the month of July and as you can see we
saw a significant deceleration across
the board in these uh indicators of core
inflation momentum trimming CPI down 461
basis points in one month median CBI
down 247 basis points sticky CPI down
270 basis points and the most important
statistic which actually is the next
chart slide 83 I sent you
core pce inflation momentum decelerated
by
629 basis points in the month of July so
if you look at an annualized month over
month rate of change basis we went from
7.3 percent to one percent one percent
and so this is very very new it's very
important information because it says
hey look some of this inflation May in
fact way very well had been transitory
and it's now starting to break down
outside of recession in a way that we've
typically never seen before in fact
there's only one other month in the
history of this time series going back
to the late 1950s where we saw such a
significant deceleration in a one-month
time Horizon and of course that was in
recession and so it's very unusual for
us to see this kind of breakdown in core
inflation momentum without a recession
which does lend some Credence to the
view that hey some of this inflation was
in fact transitory
the idea that we're still considering
whether we're in a recession or not is
wild to me uh when we see these types of
data points though does it just say okay
you know transitory not transitory
obviously there's no definition is it
three months or was it three years like
what did they mean uh but in terms of
recession is this just confirming what
kind of the the uh mainstream crowd
thinks around two consecutive quarters
of negative GDP growth now you see
something like this and you're like okay
you know there's pain here now that
we're starting to see and if this trend
continues it's only going to get worse
yes and no uh I mean yes if you wanted
to if you wanted to anchor on this and
say aha therefore we must be in
recession sure go ahead be my guest I
continue to look at a compendium
indicators namely the tightness in the
labor market uh namely the Positive
Growth we're seeing in consumer spending
still on a three-month annualized basis
we're still growing at six zero point
six percent which doesn't sound like a
lot but it's certainly not recessionary
um you know you're seeing acceleration
in disposable personal income growth you
know industrial production still
compounding to get you know two and a
half percent on on a three-month
annualized basis none of these types of
Statistics are indicate indicative of us
being in an actual recession and another
point I want to make I actually made
this point in my Mac or minute today
which is the Divergence the growing
Divergence between gross domestic income
and gross domestic product the former
being how much money the people in in
our in our geography are making relative
to the amount of stuff we're producing
and selling abroad and you know that
spread you know somewhere around 977
billion dollars now is in the 100th
percentile of quarterly data going back
to q1 of 1947. if you look at on a ratio
basis it's in the 100th percentile of
quarterly data going back to 1947 so
there's this massive spread between how
much money we're making relative to the
amount of stuff we're producing which
obviously started you know going back to
2020 when we started dumping trillions
of dollars uh into the pockets of
consumers and businesses but the real
key takeaway I'm trying to make about
this this diverges between income and
product GDP which is if you net them out
which is what the nber we talked about
the MBR a couple months ago this
business cycle dating committee that the
you know that that finds recessions in
the US you know if the MBR actually
averages out GDP and GDI and when you
average them out from a growth rate
perspective not only are they growing
steel it's actually accelerating through
the second quarter so we're very clearly
not a recession for my opinion when you
look at inflation uh we've got a chart
here that shows higher inflation begets
higher inflation volatility explain what
that means yeah absolutely so this to me
is is you know again that we have a lot
of very important questions to answer as
investors right now if we look out kind
of six to 12 months because again you
know I think the old Playbook of fat
tightening economy slows down expect an
earnings recession expected eventual fed
pivot I think that's being challenged by
the data to be quite honest with you if
you think about some of the economic
updates we've gotten for the month of
July and the month of August which
clearly shows an acceleration off the
June Lowe's and economic statistics if
we're being on it I'm always being
honest with the data I'm just not sure
anyone else is paying attention but the
reality is looking at this chart higher
inflation begets higher inflation
volatility so the blue line of the chart
just shows the U.S year-over-year
headline CPI rate going back to to
January 1881
1881 and we showed the trailing
five-year volatility of that time series
on on a percentile basis on the right
Axis and so what you typically see is
when we have higher inflation you
typically have higher inflation ball
which is exactly what we're experiencing
today and so as we look out a further um
you know further in time I think the
next chart kind of explains what I mean
by why we're looking at inflation
volatility because again when you have
higher inflation volatility you
typically sorry when you have high
inflation you typically have higher
inflation volatility which typically
leads to higher volatility in both
nominal and real economic growth which
makes it harder to forecast that's the
key Takeaway on you know kind of
expecting where we're going with this I
think we have to be a lot more data
dependent than normal from this
perspective and so what I'm showing in
this chart here
I'm showing uh on the on the x-axis of
these These Bars are showing the uh the
inflation volatility the red line and
the previous chart and I'm showing it in
quartiles so it's breaking it up in
shares of 25 and as you can see
um the first the chart on the left just
shows the volatility of s p nominal
earnings and as you can see on a
percentile basis again data going all
the way back to January of 1881. and as
you can see there's a step function
increase with the more inflation
volatility you get I.E going from the
first quartile to this the fourth
quartile you get more nominal earnings
growth volatility and the same is true
with the chart on the right you get more
real earnings volatility and so the key
takeaway here is as investors we should
not be expecting a kind of linear
processes it's not to say that it won't
happen it's just that we need to be very
aware that the kinds of linear processes
that we're used to XYZ happens with the
FED funds rate XYZ happens with the FED
balance sheet therefore X ABC must
happen with earnings growth GDP et
cetera Etc uh you know those linkages
break down where you have a lot more
volatility in the system economically
speaking
and then when you go ahead and we look
at this last chart that we have we're
still talking about the kind of higher
inflation volatility uh it also leads to
like PE multiples
yeah absolutely so you typically get
multiple compressions you have higher
inflation volatility and it makes sense
right think about go back to what we
just said higher inflation yeah it's
higher inflation volatility higher
inflation volatility begets higher
nominal and real economic growth
volatility and as a function of that
excess volatility and nominal and
economic real economic growth the market
assigns a lower multiple to the earnings
estimates and the earnings that they
they can see and so what I'm showing in
this in this chart on slide 12 is the
the price the trolling 12 months our
earnings uh ratio for the s p again this
is uh data uh going all the way back to
January 1981 or Acer 1981 1881 over 100
Years of data here and then the chart
shows the um showing that that same
analysis uh by broken up by quartiles of
inflation volatility looking at the cape
ratio that's specifically adjusted price
to earnings ratio or the PE 10 data from
my former professor at Yale uh Bob
Schiller and so what we're looking at
here is understanding hey look the more
inflation volatility you have the more
economic volatility have the lower kind
of multiples you should assign to asset
markets and kind of one key takeaway
from here is even if earnings can hang
in there which they very clearly did in
the second quarter before all being
honest as Bears if earnings can hang in
there in this sort of higher nominal GDP
kind of environment because the FED has
yet to reach a mutual or sort of
restrictive setting from the perspective
of its policy rate you still need to
assign not necessarily need to but
history would suggest that markets are
still going to assign a lower multiple
to those earnings because we're again in
a higher economic and inflation
volatility environment so to me it just
sort of caps the upside in the bullish
case scenario whereby the economy
doesn't experience a significant
downturn because oh by the way the FED
is you have to get too restrictive uh
from the perspective of its policy rate
but obviously we know what will happen
to asset markets if in fact the FED does
go into restricted when we do see the
slowdown in earnings and economic
activity how do you think about
inflation when we start getting into
this like basic fact where we know that
you know we were at a more than five
percent inflation uh starting in June
July of last year uh ended the year over
seven percent uh now that we start
seeing numbers like 8.5 percent uh in
July that seems like oh you know it's
come down but actually it's flat on a
month-to-month basis and there's
obviously this like base effect and it's
only going to get worse in the coming
months like how do you think through uh
uh how that enters into kind of your
calculations or evaluations of the
market
yeah great question man so in my opinion
I think the year-over-year inflation
statistics are more or less irrelevant
um and quite frankly they've been
Irrelevant for 18 24 months now at this
point because what's really happening on
the ground in inflation is we're
experiencing again some of this very
elevated volatility in the sequential
rates of change of inflation you know
historically we were so used to as a US
economy in the last couple of decades uh
really three decades of inflation being
somewhere between 0 to 0.1 to 0.2 Max on
a month over month you know rate a
change basis you know we've been
bouncing around between three four five
six well four one one and a half in
certain months and so that higher degree
of month over month you know annualized
inflation momentum is definitely
contributing to you know kind of a
dynamic in the market whereby us
investors in order to really get a
handle on these statistics we actually
have to look at it on on a on a month on
a momentum basis as opposed to your rate
of change basis and the reason I say
that is because this is a market that is
held on taking the easy way out in terms
of trying to front run the eventual fed
pivot and you're not gonna you're gonna
be very late to understanding the kind
of pivots that fed is going to make in
terms of their reaction function if
you're looking at you every rated chain
statistics because we're talking about
year over year rate of change we'll
still be you know four or five percent a
year from now on a year-over-year rate
of change basis but on a month over
month annualized basis three month
annualized basis you could very well be
by that point in time back at two
percent which would give the FED enough
confidence that inflation over time will
get there on a year of year rate of
change basis so or effectively I'm
trying to say is look at the leading
indicators and the leading indicators of
the month over month annualized rates of
change the three-month annualized rates
of change because they're going to beat
the year over year rate of change to the
right spot that would cause the FED
cause the FED to Pivot you know months
ahead of time so we're talking about all
of this in what I would consider very uh
uh focused view of the US economy and
obviously what's going on if you were to
talk to somebody like Zoltan over at
Credit Suisse you put out a piece last
week talking about this idea that
there's basically been two major
alliances there's been the US and China
and then there's been Europe and Russia
uh and his belief is that those two
alliances are falling apart they called
it a divorce uh and now says don't look
at the brick countries instead look at
the tricks and he basically calls out
turkey Iran Russia China North Korea uh
Etc and he's like look all these
countries that are being sanctioned by
the United States they're starting to
come together and work more closely
right and what that exactly will entail
is you know not yet understood
completely but but definitely they are
starting on an economic basis on a trade
basis on a military exercise basis it
appears like hey the enemy of my enemy
is my friend and yeah so if that plays
out uh his thought process is that that
will lead to much more conflict in the
world and one of the strong arguments he
makes is well there's been a lot of
Harmony in the world because of those
alliances and so we've lived in this low
inflation world as like a major trend
for the last couple of decades but now
if we have a reversion away from those
alliances that means trust will decrease
if trust decreases that means that
people then begin to fight over
resources fight over uh Supply chains
and labor markets and all this stuff uh
and that will likely return back to a
higher level of Baseline inflation
across the world now I know that that
theory is highly complex lots of nuance
in there but what is your general view
of like a more macro Trend basis if we
kind of zoom out and say like is it a
world where like maybe this low
inflation World we've been living in
that's over and we should just expect to
have higher Baseline inflation globally
uh in the coming years
yeah absolutely uh and so Define lower
inflation right I mean you know are we
going to stay at nine percent inflation
probably not uh we're going to settle in
our opinion uh at least according to our
model we built you know I think one is
one of the more sophisticated models
I've seen uh in the world in terms of
projecting the long-term trend of
inflation and that our model suggests
it's it's one it's forecasting an
inflection for the first time in decades
in terms of the on a sample basis
um and so that's that's noteworthy
because we've been making lower highs
and lower lows uh from an inflation time
series perspective since going back to
the early 80s and so to forecast an
inflection off the lows of 2020 is is
noteworthy in that regard but more
importantly you know we're talking about
at least according to that model which
has 16 different factors that have been
empirically proven to be uh to have uh
you know fairly uh consistent um you
know correlation and cointegration with
uh inflation you know things like
de-globalization is one of the
heavyweights in that model um which is
obviously something that as old town is
implicitly or explicitly speaking to you
know that model suggesting that you know
we're probably going to have somewhere
between 40 to 70 percent more Trend
inflation in the coming decade now that
doesn't you know it sounds like a lot in
percentage terms but in reality we're
talking about you know if you look at
core pce for instance you know we
actually averaged right at 1.6
year-over-year in core pce throughout
the 2010s the model is effectively
saying we should average somewhere
between 2.3 and 2.8 percent now again is
this really like this massive move
higher in inflation no but the reality
is the trend level of inflation is
shooting up by you know roughly 100 on
the high end 110 basis points now the
reason that matters to asset markets and
investors because we're talking about
somewhere close to 100 basis points more
inflation on a trend basis in the
Federal Reserves Target their two
percent Target and again 2.8 inflation
on trim bases is Wake Me Up when
something happens right that's a that's
a yawn but the reality is that extra 80
basis points matters because you have a
Federal Reserve that's going to
consistently see that and look at that
and need to Bang its head on a Tamara on
that um if it doesn't understand that
we're in a new world a new regime
whereby inflation not only is inflected
higher on a trend basis but it's likely
to be persistently higher than their
price stability Target I asked you this
a couple months ago uh and you said no
but I want to ask again to see if you
change your mind will the FED
potentially increase the fed target rate
from two percent to two and a half or
three percent uh given that we're living
in a higher inflation uh environment so
they just say you know what throw our
hands up like we're not actually trying
to get back to two we're trying to get
to two and a half or three percent
not in this regime not in this story not
in this particular cycle I do believe
that is ultimately uh one I think that's
the most important question we all need
to answer as investors and policy makers
in this decade uh I don't believe
they're going to do that in this
particular cycle uh and the reason I say
that one I spend a decent amount of time
kind of reading the tea leaves on
everything these people say and it's
very clear that they are trying to
maintain uh whatever control they have
over the bond market through the lens of
of depressed and negative term Premia by
being very forceful and very combative
against the current inflation surge now
when we get to you know a state of the
economy eventually they're gonna in
order to get inflation under control if
in fact most of the inflation is not
transitory which I would argue it's not
um I think you know a lot of the
transitory inflation we've we've gotten
is starting to come out we're going to
still wind up at a level that's much
higher than their their price stability
Target and so once we get to that level
you know they will have to really you
know kind of materially lean on the
economy from a restrictive policy
studying perspective and you know
perpetual lead a downturn in order to
get rid of that last little bit of
inflation and it's at that moment where
they're going to have to be faced with
some very difficult choices you know
it's it's you know it's it's you know
for lack of a better to raise it shifts
and Giggles when the unemployment rate
goes from three six to four it's it's
not it's no laughing matter when it goes
from four to six or four to seven that's
a very very different discussion at the
eckley's building uh down there in DC
where the fomc uh gathers so to me I
think when you're actually in a downturn
and they're finding it very difficult to
go from you know it's pretty easy to go
from eight and a half to five and a half
or eight and a half to four and a half
but how do you get from four and a half
to two that's the hard that's where the
difficult questions come in and I think
at that moment also enough to revise
their inflation Target higher Larry
Summers
he says we're going to have over five
percent unemployment for five years
before we get inflation under control uh
is he just laying out bombastic claims
or do you think that it is going to get
pretty bad uh in terms of the
unemployment rate right now no I mean so
the market pricing on the uh the FED
funds rate is somewhere on a terminal
basis somewhere around 3.75 to 4 percent
I'm not so sure how restricted that is
in this new economy this economy is very
clearly telling you that it has the
ability to withstand higher rates you
still have positive growth in in on an
average basis between GDI and GDP you
still have positive growth on a real
basis in terms of consumption you know
we still have positive growth on a
volume basis in terms of industrial
production and I I and I and I can see
the view that housing has really fallen
off a cliff and probably should have um
given the starting point um and there's
obviously some things that are breaking
down the economy particularly
in the economy but the reality is again
this is an economy that is growing
nominally at seven to nine percent you
know double digits recently two and a
half percent on the FED funds rate is
not restrictive it's it's we're still
technically an accommodative uh
territory which means the FED is still
kind of technically easing relative to
the kind of um growth potential in the
economy so they've got a lot of work to
do on the policy rate front uh and I'm
not so sure that we're current terminal
fed funds rate pricing is that that
constitutes doing enough work to get
that Larry Summers you know view that
we're going to have five years of five
plus percent unemployment now again if
the policy terminal fed funds rate
expectations go higher let's say into
the mid fours or even kind of mid to Mid
mid to high fours that would I think
that you know by the time we get to that
point inflation will be down nominal
growth will be down you know we'll be uh
we'll be looking at a very different
more moderated economy then I think
we'll be in a restrictive territory but
for now
no this is where I don't even know if
this is a worthwhile discussion today
yeah
for you what are investors doing
differently than maybe they were a
couple months ago how are they
positioning their portfolios what are
you seeing with your clients that
they're uh they're either talking about
or they're actually moving Capital to
position themselves for the next couple
of months you know so that's actually
really interesting man I I I and this is
you know this is something I uh going
back to the beginning of our discussion
we talked about how we got you know the
rally was sort of catalyzed by
systematic investors kind of changing
their positioning um you know kind of
unwinding some of the positioning we saw
but really from a fundamental oriented
standpoint you know there were some real
fundamental juice to this rally as I
mentioned growth accelerated we got
earnings from uh future earnings were
you know relative to expectations were
fantastic
um we actually saw some you know pretty
sizable Beats by some very important
companies and so you know we had a lot
of very good news in the month of July
throughout the month of August
um which is the breakdown inflation we
discussed at the beginning of the
program and so from that perspective you
know I I don't know that enough
investors have really acknowledged kind
of this sort of emergence of a
potentiality of a Goldilocks
self-landing because again to a person
to affirm to an investment committee
that I speak to and we have no clients
all over the world across you know
different you know asset markets
different you know pockets of the market
et cetera et cetera different big firms
small firms et cetera
everyone thinks this is a bear Market
rally and so do I I still think we're in
a bear Market but I don't believe we're
in as a the probability of us being in a
bear Market in my opinion is much lower
today than it was two months ago and I'm
not sure that the average investor
acknowledges a lot of what's changed at
the margin and direction of Goldilocks
now again Goldilocks is not the modal
outcome it's just a much higher
probability than I think the average
investor realizes and so I think the
next couple of months of data are going
to be very telling on the growth side
can we maintain this sort of nascent
positive momentum and on the inflation
side can we maintain this very
aggressive breakdown in cornflation
momentum if the answer to no is no at
least to one of those two questions then
Goldilocks will start to dissipate from
the probability standpoint if the answer
to both of those questions is no then we
are very clearly Standing Bear market
and we may in fact we have to retest
those it's at some time this uh this
fall or winter yeah it's going to be
fascinating to kind of watch how uh how
this plays out but uh the idea that um
you know Powell's talking so tough and
and uh people are reacting is exactly
what I think he wants
um and so you know it'll be funny for a
session and I'm not so sure that that is
no longer the normal outcome it's just
that we all got ahead of ourselves in
terms of anticipating it this may
actually very well be a summer of 2023
event when the FED in fact does get the
policy rate to a neutral setting or
sorry to you know restrictive setting
balance sheet unwind is actually you
know kind of pinching the economy et
cetera et cetera I just think we got too
far ahead of ourselves with the tens
two's curve inversion one thing I call
out and one thing that's given me a lot
of confidence one we're not in actual
recession and more importantly it's not
something that we should be discounting
at the current juncture because we've
yet to see the inversion in the 10-year
three month track recession I just kind
of no CBC and Bloomberg the one you the
one that has a 100 hit rate from
historical perspective nine for nine is
the 10-year three-month yield curve and
we're still positive 25 basis points
there so until that inverts I think this
concept that we you know we're heading
to recession and the economy slowing
down really significantly I think those
are kind of um those are more Finance
Twitter as opposed for you know real
economic and decision makers on Wall
Street makes uh makes complete sense
where can we send people to find you or
find out more about 42 macro yeah
appreciate it man thanks again for
having me on always a pleasure to come
come up chop it up with you my friend
um 42macro.com you know we produce uh
what I think is some of the world's best
uh institutional macro research for
everybody
um so we have you know clients to manage
trillions of dollars of clients that
manage hundreds of thousand dollars in
their pa so
um come check it out we help investors
construct uh thoughtful portfolios to
take advantage of the full range of
probable outcomes from a macroeconomic
standpoint policy standpoint et cetera I
know what I'm doing here so uh we're
excited to come uh come check us out no
by the way if you can't afford the
research but I think it's very
reasonably priced I do a lot of free
Research on Twitter as well and 42 macro
details so definitely come check us out
awesome my friend I appreciate as always
uh you coming on you have uh not only
unique views uh on the market they're
backed by data and uh you do a great job
articulating them so we'll continue to
do these every week and uh hope that
everyone's learned a lot from it looking
forward to it man thanks again
appreciate you